Resuelve, el valor absoluto de "3x" menos9 igual a 0 y grafica la solución en una recta numérica.
Y bueno, date cuenta que aquí tenemos una
ecuación con valor absoluto, el valor absoluto
de "3x" menos 9, esto es igual a 0, sin embargo
date cuenta que aquí hay algo muy importante,
si digo que el valor absoluto de algo es igual a 0,  pues esto que está dentro del valor absoluto no tiene de otra,
tiene que ser igual a 0, porque el único número al cual al aplicarle el valor absoluto nos da 0, es 0.
Por lo tanto me queda que "3x" menos 9, esto
tiene que ser igual a 0 y si "3x" menos 9
tiene que ser igual a 0, esta ecuación ya
es muy fácil de resolver,
lo único que hay que hacer es despejar a "x".
Lo importante de esta ecuación con valor
absoluto, es entender que el valor absoluto
de algo igual a 0, esto implica que ese algo, es decir, lo que está dentro del valor absoluto es 0,
es la única forma de que tengamos esta solución.
Y bueno, si ya tengo que "3x" menos 9 es igual a 0, pues voy a sumar 9 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
Estos dos se van y me queda simple y sencillamente
que "3x" es igual a 9 y después si divido
ambos lados entre 3, me queda que estos dos
se van, 3 entre 3 me da 1, 1 por "x" es "x"
y después 9 entre 3 es 3, "x" igual a 3,
es el valor que soluciona esta ecuación.
Si yo pongo "x" igual a 3 en esta ecuación,
voy a obtener como respuesta 0.
Pero después dice que también lo grafiquemos
en una recta numérica,
así que déjame hacer aquí mi recta numérica y aquí voy a poner -2, - 1, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
y hasta el 6 podríamos seguir, en fin.
Pero yo lo único que quiero es poner un pequeño
punto cuando "x" vale 3,
porque ésta es mi única solución, cuando "x" vale 3, pongo un pequeño punto y ya está.
Tengo la gráfica de esta solución.